Intuition pumps are sometimes called
thought experiments more often they're
called thought experiments,
but they're not really formal arguments.
Typically their stories,
their little fables,
uh,
in fact,
I think they're similar to aesop's
fables and that they were supposed to
have a moral.
They're supposed to teach us something
and what they do is they lead the
audience to an intuition,
a conclusion where you sort of pound
your fist on the table and you say,
oh yeah,
it's got to be that way,
doesn't it?
And if it,
if it achieves that,
then it's pumped.
The intuition that was designed to pump
these are persuasion machines,
a little persuasion machines that
philosophers have been using for several
thousand years.
I think that intuition pumps are
particularly valuable when there's
confusion about what the right questions
are and what the right,
what matters,
what matters.
To answer the question,
I think we're all pretty good at using
examples too,
to think about things.
And intuition pumps are usually rather
vivid examples that are from which
you're supposed to draw a very general
moral and they come up in many walks of
life.
Anytime you're a puzzled or confused
about what to do next or whether
something's true or false,
you might cast about for an intuition
pump that could help you.
When I first coined determined intuition
pump,
it's when Doug Hofstadter and I were
working on the mind's eye,
which has lots of intuition,
pumps,
lots of thought experiments in it,
and Doug came up with a great metaphor.
He said,
what you want to do with any of these
intuition pumps is twittle all the
knobs.
Turn the knobs,
see what makes it work.
Now though,
this is actually something that we're
familiar with from other parts of our
lives.
If there's a gadget and you want to know
what it does,
turn the knobs to see what happens,
see what,
see what the moving parts.
Do a.
So I encourage
everybody to not not just to take an
intuition pump as it's handed to them,
but look at the moving part c,
see what makes it tick.
Try to figure out what if I adjust this?
Will it still pumped the same intuition?
Well,
it's still yield the same putative
conclusion or will the whole thing fall
apart?
And it's interesting to see that a lot
of times philosophers will make an
intuition pump,
which seems to do great work until you
start turning the knobs and then you
realize that it actually depends on.
You're not thinking clearly about some
aspect of the problem.
Then you've exposed it as as not a good
intuition pump,
but as actually a sort of negative one,
I call them boom crashes because they
explode in your face.